lo que muchos dicen en Washington es que
los republicanos pues van a criticar a
todo lo que haga la administración de
Joe biden sea bueno o sea malo pero lo
van a criticar y precisamente las voces
en el congreso voces republicanas no se
han hecho esperar para criticar
precisamente que en la administración de
Joe biden haya hecho el intercambio
contra Víctor baud un Traficante de
armas bastante detenido bastante
conocido y pues lo que dicen los
republicanos es que pues el intercambio
no fue justo que al final se terminó
haciendo lo que Vladimir Putin quería
únicamente porque pues dicen que pues no
era de medirse que se intercambiará a
una basquetbolista una jugadora
profesional de baloncesto contra un
Traficante de armas que estaba condenado
en Estados Unidos por más de 25 años por
intentar conspirar para asesinar
americanos entre otros crímenes Donald
escribió en su red social
que además está basquetbolista pues era
una persona no patriótica y se hacía ese
intercambio contra una persona que le
hacía daño a el país a Estados Unidos
calificó este intercambio como una muy
mala negociación y pues se criticó
nuevamente este poder de negociación que
tenía que tiene supuestamente y que pues
según Donald Trump pues no se
materializa para haber traído a un
militar que es culpado de espionaje en
Rusia como es William pero críticos de
Donald Trump dicen que a pesar de que él
Tuvo una cercanía bastante grande con
Vladimir Putin pues no pudo traer a este
señor a este exmarin que pues es acusado
de espionaje allá en Estados Unidos en
Rusia Qué quiere decir Cristóbal esto
sobre las relaciones entre los dos
países en medio de una guerra
Pues a pesar de estas críticas de
republicanos y el propio expresidente
Donald Trump lo que están diciendo
analistas militares acá en Washington Es
uno que es importante Resaltar que
todavía hay canales de comunicación
entre Rusia y Estados Unidos a pesar de
la guerra en Ucrania a pesar de estas
voces de supuestos ataques nucleares de
Rusia y límites que pone Joe biden a
estas voces y a estos anuncios de
Vladimir Putin y segundo que pues no
solamente hay comunicación sino que se
llega a acuerdos entre los dos países a
pesar de esta guerra fría nueva guerra
fría que dice el analistas está
ocurriendo en este momento es de
Resaltar también que este es el segundo
intercambio de prisioneros que Rusia y
Estados Unidos tienen desde que empezó
la guerra en Ucrania así que pues a
pesar de estas críticas republicanas
analistas ven como positivo que estos
canales de comunicación sigan abiertos y
que se lleguen a consensos
Cristóbal